Some of the issues that arise when we try to determine relationships.
First of all, all of the indicated classes are really part of
an overarching TreeCountingSystem class, as we mentioned before.
Such system classes are not normally displayed in these diagrams. But
you can think of each of the rectangles as being a part of, or an attribute of.
The, this overarching class. The textual description from which we, began was
not truly characteristic, obviously, of typical requirements documents, which
can go on for hundreds of pages and have lots of specialized vocabulary. Also,
we went into implementation details. It was actually describing an algorithm.
Requirements documents don't necessarily describe solutions, they
describe problems. In general it is important to distinguish the analysis and
design phases of a software development effort in order to
avoid prematurely biasing the approach taken towards solution.